[MUSIC]
We are twenty months
from the 2020 election,
what if you heard from
the media about the candidates?
Maybe you've heard about how likable
they are or the odds they can win.
You probably haven't heard much about
their plans to balance the budget.
This far out from the election,
why are we even talking about polls,
why aren't we talking about policy?
On May 26, 2016,
I was working on a presidential
campaign in our headquarter's office.
I was sitting at my desk working on
briefing memos, the staff was excited that
day because at 2 o'clock our candidate
was scheduled to give a big policy speech
about workers rights in Las Vegas,
so we all wanted to watch on TV.
As 2 o'clock approached a group of
the staff peeled away from their work and
huddled around office TVs which
was set to all the major networks.
The clock ticked down, 1:58, 1:59, but
then 2 o'clock came and went, and none of
the network showed that policy speech.
Instead, all of them showed that, that's
a live feed of an empty podium at another
candidate's rally in North Dakota, waiting
for that candidate to take the stage.
That cadidate was so great for
ratings that even that image
drew people to the TV.
It was in that moment,
I thought there's a crisis with
political media in this country.
It's not a republican democrat crisis,
it's an American problem.
It's a problem of the trivial in our
political media, where personality,
scandal and polling dominate the coverage,
because that's what generates ratings and
profit.
I thought in that moment,
it's time to rethink the model
of corporate political media.
Think back to the 2016 election,
what's the first news story that comes
to mind for you about either candidate?
Raise your hand if that story was about
policy, like economic or foreign policy.
Now raise your hand if that story
was about personality, scandal, or
polling, like emails or Tweets, exactly.
In the 2016 election according to Harvard
Kennedy School, 10% of the coverage was
about policy, two-thirds was about
personality, scandal and polling.
The coverage of our elections has
become a reality show, and as a viewer,
I'm part of the problem, we all are.
It's hard to turn off the TV or not click
on the headline when it's sensationalized.
But imagine for a moment if our political
media were free from profit pressures,
free to focus only on the stories they
think the public really needs to know,
and free to pursue those stories
with depth and with context.
Over the last few weeks, I've been looking
at headlines about the 2020 candidates in
some of the leading news sites, here is
the sampling of some of those headlines.
Kamala Harris' father criticizes her for
marijuana joke,
Elizabeth Warren drinks a beer on
Instagram live and gets mixed reaction.
Grass roots not grass feed, Cory Booker
could be our first vegan president.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In the pale of winter,
Trump's tan remains a state secret.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What about TV,
if you turn on cable news in primetime,
what do you see?
It's probably one of two things,
it could be an opinion show,
where you have a partisan host delivering
a cross between an op-ed and a newscast.
Or it could be a news show,
where you probably have a split-screen
with a pundit on the left and
one on the right, talking past each other
about the hot new controversy of the day.
At the bottom of the screen in capital
letters it probably says, breaking news.
It's the same breaking news headline
whether there's been a national disaster
or if a politician made
a minor speaking geff.
So why should you care about this,
and why now?
Because reliable information is
an anchor of a functioning democracy and
we're drifting further and
further from that anchor.
Let's think about the situation we're in,
Americans are increasingly
uninformed three quarters can't name
the three branches of government.
On top of that you've all
heard about fake news,
there's a blurring of the line between
truth and fiction in our news ecosystem.
An MIT study this year found that
false news stories are 70% more
likely to get retweeted
than real new stories.
There's even an emerging AI that can mass
produce fake news making it that much
harder to detect and mitigate.
And finally less than half of
the Americans trust the mass
media that's down from 70% in the 1970s.
In this context what will happen in
the next national security emergency,
how we all agree on what's true?
We take for granted that our political
media should be run, that it's ideal for
it to be run as subsidiaries
of corporate giants.
But that system is largely failing
at what its core mission should be,
to inform and educate.
What if we considered our political
media to be a public good?
Set aside as something different from
just another product in our economy.
Quality information is essential for
people to make informed decisions,
it has benefits to our whole society.
There are already news nonprofits doing
great work like ProPublica and NPR.
And you know what the most trusted
institution in the entire country is?
PBS, we could take that model and
build a new generation of
political media non-profits.
With a strictly non-partisan
educational mission, and
with stable long term capital backing
from foundations and small donors.
One day maybe yield run a company
that owns media assets,
maybe you will be looking to invest for
impact.
When you're in that position consider
the media as part of life blood of
our democracy.
If you can be a force for
hiring journalists with
a not-for-profit nonpartisan mission.
When news rooms are getting dessimated and
pushed towards the trivial,
that's having impact.
And if you work at a social media company,
you can help partner
with quality news organizations rather
than sidelining and replacing them.
These are all long term ideas,
how can you actually help today?
It's not realistic to resolve that we'll
stop consuming infotainment all together.
But when we do consume it we could remind
ourselves that it's entertainment,
not a replacement for real news.
The Washington Post columnist Margaret
Sullivan has said that in an election,
the media treats policy like
a helping of steamed broccoli,
shoved to the side of the plate.
Broccoli gets a bad rap but
it's healthy and it's really important for
a balanced diet, maybe we can
make a small pledge here today.
For every few stories we consume between
now and 2020 about the political horse
race, we could try to find and real and
maybe even share a story about policy.
In the strongest democracy in the world,
we can build a new landscape
of political media.
A media we can be proud off that rises
above the fray to deliver substance and
context.
You can help make that a reality,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]